the following is a conversation with
brian johnson founder of kernel
a company that has developed devices
that can monitor
and record brain activity and previously
he was the founder of braintree
a mobile payment company that acquired
venmo and then was acquired by paypal
and ebay
quick mention of our sponsors for
sigmatic
netsuite grammarly and expressvpn
check them out in the description to
support this podcast
as a side note let me say that this was
a fun and memorable experience
wearing the kernel flow brain interface
in the beginning of this conversation
as you can see if you watch the video
version of this episode
and there's a ubuntu linux machine
sitting next to me collecting the data
from my brain
the whole thing gave me hope that the
mystery of the human mind
will be unlocked in the coming decades
as we begin to measure signals from the
brain
in a high bandwidth way to understand
the mind we either have to
build it or to measure it both
are worth a try thanks to brian and the
rest of the colonel team for making this
little demo happen
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here
is my conversation with brian johnson
you ready lex yes i'm ready do you guys
want to come in
and put the interfaces on our heads and
then i will proceed to tell you a few
jokes
so we uh we have two incredible pieces
of technology and
a machine running ubuntu 2004 in front
of us
what are we doing all right are these
going on our heads they're going on our
heads yeah
and they will place it on our heads for
proper alignment
does this support giant heads because i
kind of have a giant head
is this is just as like an ego or are
you saying
physically both
it's a nice massage yes
okay how does it feel it moves around
it's okay to move around yeah it feels
oh yeah
[Music]
this feels awesome thank you that feels
good
so this is big head friendly it suits
you well lex
thank you i
feel like i need to uh i feel like when
i wear this i need to sound like sam
harris calm
collected eloquent
i feel smarter actually i don't think
i've ever felt
quite as much like i'm part of the
future as now have you ever
worn a brain interface or had your brain
imaged
oh uh never had my brain imaged
the only way i've analyzed my brain is
by uh
talking to myself and thinking no direct
data
yeah yeah that is it that is definitely
an interface
that has a lot of blind spots it has
some blind spots
yeah psychotherapy that's right
all right are we recording
all right so lex the objective
of this i'm going to
tell you some jokes and your objective
is to not smile
which as a russian you should have an
edge
make the motherland proud i gotcha okay
let's hear the jokes lex and this is
from the kernel crew
we've been working on a device that can
read your mind
and we would love to see your thoughts
is that the joke that's the opening okay
if if i'm if i'm seeing the muscle
activation correctly on your
on your lips you're not gonna do well on
this let's see all right here here comes
the first unscrewed here comes the first
one
is this gonna break the device is it
resilient
to uh to laughter
lex what goes through a potato's brain
i got already failed that's the
hilarious opener okay
what tater thoughts
what kind of fish performs brain surgery
i don't know a neural surgeon
and so we're getting data of everything
that's happening in my brain right now
lifetime yeah we're getting
activation patterns of your entire
cortex
i'm gonna try to do better i'll edit out
all the parts where i left
photoshop you serious face over me you
can recover
all right lex what do scholars eat
when they're hungry i don't know what
academia
nuts
that's a pretty one so what we'll do
is so you're wearing
kernel flow which is
an interface built uh using technology
called spectroscopy so it's similar to
what we wear
wearables on the wrist using light so
using lidar as you know
and we're using that to image
it's a functional imaging of brain
activity and so as your neurons fire
electrically and and chemically it
creates
uh blood oxygenation levels we're
measuring that and so in you'll see in
the reconstructions we do for you
you'll see your activation patterns in
your brain as throughout this entire
time we are wearing it
so in the reaction to the jokes and as
we were sitting here talking
so it's a we're moving towards a
real-time
feed of your cortical brain activity so
there's a bunch of
things that are in contact with my skull
right now how many of them are there and
so how many of them are
what are they what are the actual
sensors there's 52
modules and each module has one laser
and six
sensors and they're the sensors fire
uh in about 100 picoseconds and then the
photons scatter and absorb in your brain
and then a few go in if you come back
out they a bunch go in that a fuel come
back out and we
sense those photons and then we do the
reconstruction for the activity
overall there's about a thousand plus
channels
that are sampling your activity how
difficult is it to make it as
comfortable as it is
because it's surprisingly comfortable i
would not think it would be comfortable
something that's measuring brain
activity
i would not think it would be
comfortable but it is i agree in fact i
want to take this home
yeah yeah that's right so people are
accustomed
to being in big systems like fmri where
there's 120 decibel sounds and you're in
a claustrophobic
encasement or eeg which is just painful
or surgery and so yes i agree that this
is a
convenient option to be able to just put
on your head it measures your brain
activity in the contextual environment
you choose so if we
want to have it during the podcast if we
want to be at home in a business setting
so we it's freedom to be where to record
your brain activity in the setting that
you choose
yeah but sort of from an engineering
perspective are these uh
what is it there's a bunch of different
modular parts and they're kind of
there's like a rubber band thing where
they they mold to the shape of your head
that's right so we we built this this
version of the mechanical design
to accommodate most adult heads
but i have a giant head and if it's fine
it feels fits well actually
so i don't think i have an average head
okay maybe i feel i feel much better
about my head now maybe i'm
uh i'm more average than i thought
okay so what else is there interesting
you could say what's up
while it's on our heads i can keep this
on the whole time this is kind of
awesome
and it's amazing for me as a fan of
ubuntu i use a bunch of mate you guys
should use
that too but it's amazing to have code
running
to the side measuring stuff and
collecting data
i mean that i just i feel like much more
important now
that my data is being recorded like
somebody care
like you know when you you have a good
friend that listens to you
that actually like listens like actually
is listening to you this is what i feel
like
i'm like a much better friend because
it's like accurately listening to me
upon two what a cool perspective i
hadn't thought about that
of feeling understood yeah heard
yeah heard deeply by the mechanical
system
that is recording your brain activity
versus the human
that you're engaging with that your mind
immediately goes to
that there's this dimensionality and
depth of understanding
yeah of this software system which
you're intimately familiar with
and now you're able to communicate with
this system in ways that you couldn't
before
yeah i feel heard
yeah i mean i guess what's interesting
about this is your intuitions are
spot on most people have intuitions
about brain interfaces that
they've grown up with this idea of
people moving cursors on the screen or
typing or changing the channel or
skipping a song it's
primarily been anchored on control and
i think the more relevant understanding
of brain
interfaces or neural imaging is that
it's a measurement system
and once you have numbers for a given
thing
a seemingly endless number of
possibilities emerge around that of what
to do with those numbers
so before you tell me about the
possibilities this was an incredible
experience
i can keep this on for another two hours
but i'm being
told that uh for a bunch of reasons
just because we probably want to keep
the data small and visualize it nicely
for the final product we want to cut
this off and take this
to take this amazing helmet away from me
so
brian thank you so much for this
experience and let's uh
let's continue without helmetless all
right
so that was an incredible experience uh
can you maybe speak to
what kind of opportunities that opens up
that stream of data that rich stream of
data from the brain
first i'm curious what is your reaction
what
what comes to mind when you put that on
your head what does it mean to you
and what possibilities emerge and what
significance might it have i mean i'm
curious where
your orientation is at well
for me i'm really excited by the
possibility of
various information about my body about
my mind
being converted into data such that data
can be used to create
products that make my life better so
that that means really exciting
possibility
even just like a fitbit that measures i
don't know
some very basic measurements about your
body is really cool
but it's the the bandwidth of
information
the resolution of that information is
very crude so it's not very interesting
the possibility of recording of just
building a data set
coming in a clean way in a high
bandwidth way from
my brain opens up uh
all kinds of you know at the very i was
kind of joking when we're talking but
it's not really it's like i feel heard
in the sense that it feels like
the full richness of the information
coming from my mind
is actually being recorded by the
machine i mean there's a i can't
i can't quite put it into words but
there is a genuinely for me
this is not some kind of joke about me
being a robot is this genuinely feels
like i'm being
heard uh in a way that uh
that's going to improve my life as long
as the thing that's on the other end
can do something useful with that data
but even the the recording itself
is like once you record it's like taking
a picture
that moment is forever saved in time
now a picture cannot allow you to step
back
into that world but perhaps
recording your brain is a much higher
resolution thing
much more personal recording of that
information than a picture
that would allow you to step back into
that
where you were in that particular moment
in history
and then map out a certain trajectory to
tell you certain things about
uh about yourself that could open up all
kinds of applications
of course there's health that i consider
but honestly
to me the exciting thing is just being
heard my state of mind
the level of focus all those kinds of
things being heard
what i heard you say is you have an
entirety of
lived experience some of which you can
communicate in words
and in body language some of which you
feel internally
which cannot be captured in those
communication modalities and that this
measurement system
captures both the things you can try to
articulate in words maybe in a lower
dimensional
space using one word for example to
communicate focus
yeah when it really may be represented
in a 20 dimensional space of
this particular kind of focus and that
this information is being captured so
it's a closer representation to the
entirety
of your experience captured in a dynamic
fashion that is not just
a static image of your conscious
experience
yeah yeah that that's that's that's the
promise that's the hope that was the
feeling
and it felt like the future so it's a
pretty cool experience and from the sort
of
mechanical perspective it was cool to
have an actual device that
feels pretty good that doesn't uh
doesn't require me to go into the lab
and also the other thing i was i was
feeling there's a guy named andrew
huberman
he's a friend of mine amazing podcast
people should uh uh should listen to a
humor in the lab podcast
we're working on a paper together about
eye movement and so on
and we're kind of he's a neuroscientist
and i'm a data person a machine learning
person and
we're we're both excited by
how much the that
how much the data measurements of the
human mind
the brain and all the different metrics
that come from that
can be used to understand human beings
and
in a rigorous scientific way so the
other thing i was thinking about is how
this could be turned into
a tool for science sort of not just
personal science not just like
fitbit style like uh how am i doing
my personal metrics of health but doing
larger scale studies of human behavior
and so on
so like data not at the scale of an
individual but data at a scale of many
individuals or a large number of
individuals so
science so it's personal being heard was
exciting and also just
for science is exciting it's very easy
like there's a very powerful thing to it
being so easy to just put on
that you can scale much easier if you
think about the second thing you said
about
the science of
the brain most
we've done a pretty good job like we the
human race has done a pretty good job
figuring out how to quantify the things
around us from distance
stars to calories and steps
and our genome so we can measure and
quantify
pretty much everything in the known
universe
except for our minds and we can do these
one-offs if we're going to get an fmri
scan or
do something with the low-res eeg system
but we haven't done this at
population scale and so if you think
about
human thought or human cognition is
probably
the single law largest raw input
material into society at any given
moment
it's our conversations with our with
ourselves and with other people
and we have this this raw input that we
can't haven't been able to measure yet
yeah
and if you when i think about it through
that frame
it's remarkable it's almost like we live
in this
wild wild west of unquantified
communications within ourselves
and between each other when everything
else has been grounded me for example i
know if i buy an appliance at this
at the store or on a website i don't
need to
look at the measurements on the
appliance make sure it can fit through
my door
that's an engineered system of appliance
manufacturing and construction
everyone's agreed upon
engineering standards and we don't
have engineering standards around
cognition it's not a for it has not
entered as a formal engineering
discipline
that enables us to scaffold in society
with everything else we're doing
including consuming news our
relationships
politics economics education all the
above
and so to me that the most significant
contribution that kernel technology has
to offer
would be the formal sca the
introduction of the formal engineering
of cognition as it relates to everything
else in society
i love that i idea that you kind of
think
that there is just this ocean of data
that's coming from people's brains as
being in a crude way reduced down to
like
tweets and texts and so on just a very
hardcore mini scale compression of
actual the raw data but maybe you can
comment
because you use the word cognition
i think the first step is to get the
brain data
but um is there a leap
to be taking to sort of interpreting
that data in terms of cognition
so is your is your ideas basically you
need to start collecting data at scale
from the brain and then we start to
really be able to
take little steps along the path to
actually
measuring some deep sense of cognition
because it's
you know as i'm sure you know we don't
we understand
a few things but we don't understand
most of what makes up cognition
this has been one of the most
significant challenges of building
kernel
and colonel wouldn't exist if i wasn't
able to fund it initially by myself
because when i engage in conversations
with investors
the immediate thought is what is the
killer app
and of course i understand that
heuristic that's what they're looking at
is they're looking to de-risk
is the product solved is there a
customer base are people willing to pay
for it how does it compare to competing
options
and in the case with brain interfaces
when i started the company
there was no known path to even build a
technology that could potentially
become mainstream yes and then once we
figured out the technology
we could even we could commence having
conversations with investors and it
became
what is a killer app and so what has
been
so i've funded the first 53 million
dollars of the company
and to raise the round of funding the
first one we did i spoke to 228
investors
one said yes it was remarkable and it
was
mostly around this concept around what
is a killer app and
so internally the way we think about it
is we think of the
the go-to-market strategy much more like
the drake equation
where if we can build technology that
has
the characteristics of it has the data
quality is high enough it meets some
certain threshold
cost accessibility comfort
it can be worn in contextual
environments if it meets the criteria
of being a mass-market device then
the responsibility that we have is to
figure out how to
create the algorithm that enables
the human to enable
uh humans to then find value with it
okay so it so the analogy is like
brain interfaces are like early 90s of
the internet is you
you want to populate an ecosystem with a
certain number of devices you want a
certain number of people
who play around with them who do
experiments of certain data collection
parameters you want to encourage certain
mistakes from experts to non-experts
these are all
critical elements that ignite discovery
and so
we believe we've accomplished the first
objective building technology
that reaches those thresholds and now
it's the drake equation component of
how do we try to
generate 20 years of value discovery in
a two or three year time period how do
we compress that
so just to clarify so when you mean the
drake equation
uh which for people who don't know i
don't know why you if you listen to this
i bring up aliens every single
conversation so
it's i don't know how you would know
what the drake equation is but you mean
like the killer app it would be one
alien civilization in that equation
so meaning like this is in search of an
application that's
impactful transformative by the way it
should be a we need to come up with a
better term
than killer app as a it's also violent
right
very violent you can go like viral app
that's horrible too
right it's some very uh inspiringly
impactful application how about that no
yeah okay so let's stick with killer app
that's fine
nobody's but i concur with you i dislike
the chosen words in in capturing the
concept
you know it's one of those sticky things
that uh is as
effective to use in the tech world but
when you
now become a communicator outside of the
tech world especially when you're
talking about software and hardware and
artificial intelligence applications it
sounds horrible you know it's
interesting i
i actually regret now having called
attention because i regret having used
that word in this conversation
because it's something i would not
normally do i i used it
in order to create a bridge of shared
understanding of how others would what
terminology others would use
yeah but yeah i concur let's go with the
impactful application value creation
value creation something people love
using
there we go that's it love app
okay so what uh do you have any ideas so
you're basically creating a framework
where there's
the possibility of a discovery of uh
an application that people love using
is do you have ideas we've began to play
a fun game internally where when we have
these discussions and we
begin circling around this concept of
does anybody have an idea does anyone
have intuitions and
if we see the conversation starting to
to veer in that direction
we flag it and say human intuition alert
stop it and so we really want to focus
on the algorithm
of there's a natural process of human
discovery
that that when you populate a system
with devices and you give people the
opportunity to play around with it in
expected and unexpected ways
we are thinking that is a much better
system of discovery
than us exercising tuitions and it's
interesting we're also seeing a few
neural scientists who have been
have been talking to us where i was
speaking just one young
associate professor and i approached a
conversation and said hey
we have these five data streams that
we're pulling off
when you hear that what weighted value
do you add to each data source like
which one do you think is going to be
valuable for your objectives
and which one's not and he said i don't
care just give me the data
all i care about is my machine learning
model but importantly he did not have a
theory of mind he did not come to the
table and say i think
the brain operates you know in this way
and these regions that have these these
functions
he didn't care he just wanted the data
and we're seeing that more and more
that certain people
are devaluing human intuitions for good
reasons as we've seen in machine
learning over
over the past couple years and we're
doing the same in our value creation
uh market strategy
so more collect more data clean data
make uh the products such that the
collection of data is uh
easy and and and fun and then the the
rest will just
spring to life that's right through
humans
playing around with them our objective
is to create the most valuable
data collection system of the brain ever
and with that then applying all the
best tools of machine learning and other
techniques to extract out you know
to try to find insight but yes our
objective is really to systematize the
discovery process because we
we can't put definite time frames on
discovery
the brain is complicated and and science
is not a business strategy
and so we really need to figure out how
to
this is the difficulty of bringing
bringing you know technology like this
to market it's why
most of the time it just ling it
languishes
in academia academia for quite some time
but we hope that
we will over you know cross over and
make this mainstream in the coming years
the thing was cool to wear but what's uh
are you chasing a good reason for
millions of people to put it
this on their head and keep on their
head regularly
is there um like who's going to discover
that reason
is it going to be people just kind of
organically
or is there going to be a angry bird
style application
that's just uh too exciting to
to not use if i think through the things
that
have changed my life most significantly
over the past few years
when i started wearing a wearable in my
wrist
that would give me data about my heart
rate heart rate variability respiration
rate
metabolic approximations etc
for the first time in my life i had
access to information
uh sleep patterns that were highly
impactful
they they told me for example if i eat
close to bedtime i'm not going to get
deep sleep
and not getting deep sleep means you
have all these follow-on consequences in
life and so
it opened up this window of
understanding of myself
that i cannot self-introspect and deduce
these things this is information that
was
available to be acquired but it just
wasn't i would have to
get an expensive sleep study then it's
an end like one night and that's not
good enough to look
to run all my trials and so if you look
just at the information
that one can acquire on their wrist and
now you're applying planted to the
entire cortex on the brain
and you say what kind of information
could we acquire
it opens up a whole new universe of
possibilities
for example we did this internal study
at kernel where i wore a prototype
device
and we were measuring the cognitive
effects of sleep
so i had a device measuring my sleep i
performed with 13 of my
my co-workers we performed four
cognitive tasks over
13 sessions and we focused on reaction
time
impulse control short-term memory
and then a resting state task and we
with mine we found for example that
my impulse control was independently
correlated with my sleep
outside of behavioral measures of my
ability to play the game the point
of the study was i had the brain study i
did at colonel
confirmed my life experience that if i
my deep sleep determined whether or not
i would be able to resist
temptation the following day and my
brain didn't show that
as one example and so if you start
thinking if you actually have
uh data on yourself on your on your
entire cortex you can control the
settings i think there's probably an
uh a large number of things that we
could discover about ourselves
very very small and very very big i just
for example like when you read
news what's going on like when you use
social media when you use news what
like uh all the ways we allocate
attention
that's right with the computer i mean
that seems like a compelling place to
where you would
want to put on uh kernel by the way what
is it called kernel flux kernel like
what flow
fluid yeah two technologies uh flow flow
okay so when you when you put on the the
kernel flow
it it is seems like to be um
a compelling time and place to do it is
when you're behind a desk behind a
computer
because you could probably wear it for
prolonged periods of time
as you're as you're taking in content
and there could a lot of
because some of our so much of our lives
happens in the digital world now
that kind of coupling the information
about the human mind
with the consumption and the behaviors
in the digital world might give us a lot
of information about the effects
of the way we behave and navigate the
digital world
to the actual physical meat space
uh effects on our body it's interesting
to think so in terms of both like
for work i i'm a big fan of uh
cal newport his ideas of deep work
that uh i spend uh
with few exceptions i try to spend the
first two hours of every day
usually if i'm like at home and have
nothing on my schedule
is going to be up to eight hours of deep
work or focus zero distraction
and for me to analyze the i mean i'm
very aware of the
uh the waning of that the ups and downs
of that
and it's almost like you you're surfing
the ups and downs of that as you're
doing programming as you're doing
thinking about particular problems
you're trying to visualize things in
your mind you
start trying to stitch them together
you're trying to uh
when there's a dead end about an idea
you have to kind of
calmly like walk back and start again
all those kinds of processes it'd be
interesting to get data on what my mind
is actually doing
and also recently started doing uh i
just talked to
sam harris a few days ago and been uh
building up to that i started using
started meditating using his app waking
up but
very much uh recommend it it'd be
interesting to get data on that
because it's you're very it's like
you're removing all the noise
from your head and you're very much it's
an active process of
active noise removal active noise
cancelling
like the headphones and it'd be
interesting to see what is going on in
the mind
uh before the meditation during it and
after all those kinds of things
and in all of your examples it's
interesting that
everyone who's designed an experience
for you so whether it be the meditation
app
or the deep work or with all the things
you mentioned
they constructed this product with a
certain
number of knowns yeah now what if
we expanded the number of knowns by 10x
or 20x or 30x
they would reconstruct their product
cool incorporate those known so it'd be
yeah and so this is the dimensionality
that i think is
the promising aspect is that people will
be able to
use this quantification use this
information
to build more effective products and
this is i'm not talking about
better products to advertise to you or
manipulate you i'm talking about uh
our focus is helping people individuals
have this contextual awareness and
quantification and then to engage with
others who are
seeking to improve people's lives that
the objective is
is betterment across ourselves
individually and also
uh with each other yeah so it's a nice
data stream to have if you're building
an app
like if you're building a podcast
listening app it would be nice to know
data about the listener
so that like if you're bored or you fell
asleep maybe pause the podcast
it's like really dumb just very simple
applications
that could just improve the quality of
the experience of the using the app
and imagining if you have you have your
neuron this is lex
and you there's a statistical
representation of you
and you engage with the app and it says
lex
your best to engage with this meditation
exercise in the following settings at
this time of day
after eating this kind of food or not
eaten fasting
with this level of blood glucose and
this kind of night's sleep
but all these data combined
to give you this contextually relevant
experience just like we do with our
sleep we you've optimized your entire
life
based upon what information you can
acquire and know about yourself
and so the question is how much do we
really know
of the things going around us and i
would venture to guess in my own my life
life experience
i capture my self-awareness captures an
extremely small
percent of the things that actually
influence my conscious
and unconscious experience well in some
sense the data would
help encourage you to be more self-aware
not just because you
trust everything the data is saying but
is it'll give you a prod to start
investigating
like i would love to get like a a rating
like a ranking of all the things i do
and what are the things this is probably
important to do without the data but the
data will certainly help it's like
rank all the things you do in life and
which ones make you feel shitty which
must make you feel good
like uh you're talking about evening
brian like uh
this is a good example somebody like
i do pig out at night as well
and uh and it never makes like you're in
a safe space
this is just a safe space let's hear it
no i i definitely have much less
self-control at night and it's
interesting
and the same you know um people might
criticize this but
i i know my own body i know when i eat
carnivore just eat meat
i feel much better uh
than uh if i eat more
more carbs the more cups i eat the worse
i feel i don't know why that is
i don't i there is science supporting
but i'm not leading on science i'm
leaning on personal experience and
that's really important
i don't need to read i'm not going to go
in a whole rant about nutrition science
but
many of those studies are very flawed
they're doing their best but nutrition
science is a very difficult
uh field of study because humans are so
different
and the mind has so much impact on the
way your body
behaves and it's so difficult from a
scientific perspective to conduct really
strong studies
that you have to be almost like a
scientist of an
of one you have to do these studies on
yourself that's the best way to
understand what works for you or not
and i don't understand why because it
sounds unhealthy but eating only meat
always makes me feel good just eat eat
meat that's it
and i don't have any allergies and you
know that kind of stuff
i'm not full like jordan peterson where
like if he like deviates a little bit
that he goes off like deviates a little
bit from the carnivore diet he goes off
like the cliff no i can i can have like
chalk i can i can go off the diet i feel
fine it's not it's a it's a gradual
uh it's a gradual worsening
of how i feel but what i eat only meat i
feel great
and it'd be nice to be reminded of that
like there's a very simple fact
that i feel good when i eat carnivore
and i think that repeats itself in
all kinds of experiences like i feel
really good
uh when i exercise
not i hate exercise okay but
in the rest of the day the the uh the
impact it has
on my mind and the clarity of mind and
the experiences and the happiness and
all those kinds of things i feel really
good and to be able to
concretely express that through data
would be would be nice it would be a
nice reminder almost like a statement
like
remember what feels good and what not
and there could be things like
uh that i'm not many things like just
you're suggesting that i could
not be aware of they might be sitting
right in front of me
that uh make me feel really good and
make me feel not good
and the data would show that i agree
with you i've actually
employed the same strategy i i fired my
mind entirely
from being responsible for constructing
my diet
so i started doing a program where i now
track over 200 biomarkers
every 90 days and it captures
of course the things you would expect
like cholesterol but also dna
methylation
and all kinds of things that about my
body all the processes that make up
me and then i let that data generate the
shopping list
and so i never actually ask my mind what
it wants it's entirely what my body
is reporting that it wants and so i call
this goal alignment
within brian and there's 200 plus actors
that i'm currently asking their opinion
of
and so i'm asking my liver how are you
doing and it's expressing
via the biomarkers and so then i
construct that diet
and i only eat those foods until my next
testing round
and that has changed my life more than i
think anything else
because in the emotion of my conscious
mind that i gave primacy to my entire
life it led me astray because like you
were saying
the mind then goes out into the world
and it navigates
the dozens of different dietary regimens
people put together in books and it all
has
al their their supporting science in
certain contextual settings but it's not
n of one
and like you're saying this dietary
really is an end of one
these what people have published
scientifically of course can be used
for nice groundings but it changes when
you get to the end of one level
and so that's what gets me excited about
brainerd faces is if you
if i could do the same thing for my
brain where i can stop asking my
conscious mind
for its advice or for its decision
making which is
flawed and i'd rather just look at this
data that and i've i've never had better
health markers in my life than when i
stopped
actually asking myself to be in charge
of it and
the idea of uh the motion of the
conscious mind
is uh is such a sort of engineering way
of phrasing like meditation with
what they mean that's what we're doing
right yeah that's beautiful that means
really beautifully put
by the way testing around what does that
look like what's that
well you mentioned uh yeah the very the
test i do
yes so includes a complete
blood panel i do a microbiome test i do
a food inflammation of diet
induced inflammation so i look for
excited kind expressions so foods that
produce inflammatory reactions
i look at my neural endocrine systems i
look at all my neural transmitters
i do yeah there's several micronutrient
tests to see how i'm looking at the very
various nutrients
what about like self report of
like how you feel you know almost like
um
you can't demote your con you still
exist within your conscious mind
right so that lived experience of is of
a lot of value so how do you measure
that i do a temporal sampling
over some duration of time so i'll think
through how i feel
over a week over a month over three
months i don't do a temporal sampling of
if i'm at the grocery store in front of
a cereal box and be like
you know what captain crunch is probably
the right thing for me today because i'm
feeling like
i need a little fun in my life yeah and
so it's a temporal sampling if the data
set's large enough then i i smooth out
the function of my natural oscillations
of how i feel about life where some days
i may
feel upset or depressed or down or
whatever and i don't want those moments
to then rule my decision making that's
why
the demotion happens and it says really
if you're looking at health over 90 day
period of time
all my 200 voices speak up on that
interval
and they're all given voice to say this
is how i'm doing and this is what i want
and so it really is an accounting system
for everybody so that's why
i think that if you think about the
future of being human
there's two things i think that are
really going on
one is the design manufacturing and
distribution of intelligence
is heading towards zero con a cost curve
over over a certain design over a
certain time frame
but our ability to you know evolution
produced us
an intelligent form of intelligence we
are now designing our own intelligence
systems
and the design manufacturing
distribution of that intelligence over a
certain
uh time frame is going to go to a cost
of zero
design manufacture distribution of
intelligent
cost is going to zero again
just give me a second okay that's
brilliant okay
and evolution is doing the design
manufacturing distribution of
intelligence and now we are doing
the design manufacturing distribution of
intelligence
and the cost of that is going to zero
that's a very
uh nice way of looking at life on earth
so if that that's going on and then now
in parallel
to that then you say okay what
what then happens if when that cost
curve is heading
to zero our existence becomes
a goal alignment problem a goal
alignment function
and so the same thing i'm doing where
i'm doing goal alignment within myself
of these 200 biomarkers where i'm saying
when when brian exists on a daily basis
and this entity is deciding what to eat
what to do and et cetera
it's not just my conscious mind which is
opining it's
200 biological processes and there's a
whole bunch more voices involved
so in that equation
we're going to increasingly automate
the things that we spend high energy on
today because it's easier
and now we're going to then negotiate
the terms and conditions of intelligent
life now we say conscious existence
because we're biased because that's what
we have
but it will be the largest computational
exercise in history because you're now
doing go alignment
with planet earth within yourself with
each other
within all the intelligent agents we're
building bots and other you know voice
assistants
you basically i don't have a trillions
and trillions of agents working on
the negotiation of goal alignment yeah
this this is in fact true uh and what
was the second thing
that was it so the cost the design
manufacturing distribution of
intelligence going to zero
which then means what's really going on
what are we really doing
we're negotiating the terms and
conditions
of existence do you worry about
the survival of this process
that uh life as we know it on earth
comes to an end
or at least intelligent life that as the
cost goes to zero
all something happens where uh
all of that intelligence is thrown in
the trash by
something like nuclear war or
development of agi systems that are very
dumb
not agi i guess but ai is just that it's
the paper clip thing
what on mass is dumb but has unintended
consequences to where it destroys human
civilization
do you worry about those kinds of things
i mean it's it's unsurprising
that a new thing comes into
the sphere of human consciousness humans
identify the foreign object in this case
artificial intelligence our amygdala
fires up and says
scary foreign
we should be apprehensive about this and
so it
makes sense from a biological
perspective that humans
for the the knee-jerk reaction is fear
what i don't think has been properly
weighted with that is that
we are the first generation of
intelligent beings on this earth
that has been able to look out over
their expected lifetime
and see there is a real possibility of
evolving
into entirely novel forms of
consciousness
yeah so different that it would be
totally
unrecognizable to us today we don't have
words for it we can't hint at it we
can't point at it we can't
you can't look in the sky and see that
thing that is shining we're going to go
up there
you you cannot even create an
aspirational
statement about it and
instead we've had this knee-jerk
reaction of fear
about everything that could go wrong but
in my estimation
this should be the defining aspiration
of all intelligent life on earth that
that we would aspire
that basically every generation surveys
the landscape of possibilities they're
afforded
given the technological cultural and
other contextual situation that they're
in
we're in this context we haven't yet
identified this and said
this is unbelievable we should carefully
think this thing through
not just of mitigating the things that
wipe us out like we have
this potential and so we just haven't
given voice to it
even though it's within this realm of
possibilities so you're excited about
the possibility of
super intelligence systems and what the
opportunities that bring i mean
there's parallels to this you think
about people before the internet
as the internet was coming to life
i mean there's kind of a fog through
which you can't see
what does the future look like
like predicting collective intelligence
which i don't think we're understanding
that we're
living through that now is that there's
now we've
we've in some sense stopped being
individual intelligences
and become much more like collective
intelligences
because ideas travel much much
faster now and they can in a viral way
like sweep across the populations and so
it's almost
i mean it almost feels like a thought
is had by many people now thousands or
millions of people as opposed to an
individual person
and that's changed everything but to to
me i don't think we're realizing how
much that actually changed in people
or societies but like to predict that
before the internet
would have been very difficult and in
that same way we're sitting here
with the fog before us thinking what is
uh super intelligent systems how is that
going to change
the world what is uh increasing the
bandwidth like
uh plugging our brains into this whole
thing how is that going to change the
world
and it seems like it's a fog you don't
know
and it could be it could uh
whatever comes to be could destroy the
world that this we could be the last
generation
but it also could uh transform in in
ways that creates a an incredibly
fulfilling life experience that's
unlike anything we've ever experienced
it might involve dissolution of ego and
consciousness and so on you're no longer
one individual
it might be more you know
that might be a certain kind of death
and ego death but the experience might
be really exciting and enriching
maybe we'll live in a virtual like it's
like it's it's
it's funny to think about a bunch of
sort of hypothetical questions of
would it be more
fulfilling to live in a virtual world
like if you were able to plug your brain
in
in a very dense way into a video game
like which world would you want to live
in in the video game
or in the physical world for most of us
we're kind of
touring it with the idea of the video
again but we still want to live in the
physical world have friendships and
relationships
in the physical world but we don't know
that
again it's a fog and maybe maybe in a
hundred years we're all living inside a
video game
hopefully not call of duty hopefully
more like
like sims 5 which version is it on
for you individually though does it make
you
sad that your brain ends
that you die one day very soon
that the whole thing that that uh that
data source
just goes offline sooner than you would
like
that's a complicated question i would
have answered it
differently in different times in my
life i
you know had chronic depression for 10
years and so in that 10-year time period
i desperately wanted lights to be off
and the thing that made it even worse is
i was in a religious
i was born into a religion it was the
only reality i ever understood and it's
difficult to articulate to people
when you're born into that kind of
reality and it's the only reality you're
exposed to
you're literally blinded to the
existence of other realities
because it's so much the in-group out
group thing
and so in that situation it was not only
that i desperately wanted lights out
forever
it was that i couldn't have lights out
forever it was there was an afterlife
and this afterlife had this
system that would either penalize or or
reward you for your behaviors and so
it's almost like this
is indescribable hopelessness
of not only being in hopeless despair
of not wanting to exist but then also
being forced to be to exist
and so there was a duration of my time
of the observation of life where i'd say
yes i have no remorse
for lights being out and actually want
it more than anything in the entire
world
there are other times where i'm looking
out at the future and i say
this is an opportunity for future
evolving human conscious experience that
is beyond
my ability to understand and and i jump
out of bed and i race to work and i
i can't think about anything else but i
i think the the reality for me
is i don't know what it's like to be in
your head but in my head
when i wake up in the morning i don't
say
good morning brian i'm so happy to see
you like i'm sure
you're just going to be beautiful to me
today you're not going to make a huge
long list of everything you should be
anxious about
you're not going to repeat that list to
me 400 times you're not going to have me
relive all the regrets i've made in life
i'm sure you're not doing any of that
you're just going to
just help me along all day long i mean
it's a
brutal environment in my brain and we've
just become
normalized to this environment that we
just accept that this is what it means
to be human
but if we look at it if we try to muster
as much soberness as we can
about the realities of being human it's
brutal
if it is for me and so
am i sad that the brain may be off one
day
yeah it depends on the contextual
setting like how am i feeling what
moment are you asking me that and that's
it's my mind is so fickle
and this is why again i don't trust my
conscious mind i have been
given realities i was given a religious
reality
that was a video game and then i figured
out it was not
a real reality and then i lived in a
depressive reality which delivered
this terrible hopelessness that wasn't a
real reality then i discovered
uh behavioral psychology and i figured
out how biased 188 chronicle biases and
how my brain is distorting reality all
the time
i have gone from one reality to another
i don't
trust reality i don't trust realities
are given to me
and so to make try to make a decision on
what i value or not value that future
state
i don't trust my response so not
fully not fully listening to
the conscious mind at any one moment as
the ultimate truth
but allowing it to go up and down as it
does and just kind of being observing it
yes i assume that whatever my conscious
mind delivers up
to my awareness is wrong
on pawn landing and i just need to
figure out where it's wrong how it's
wrong how wrong it is
and then try to correct for it as best i
can but i i assume
that on impact it's mistaken in some
critical ways
is there something you can say by way of
advice
when the mind is depressive when the
conscious mind serves up
something that uh you know
the dark thoughts how you deal with that
how in your own life you've overcome
that and others who are experiencing
that
can overcome it two things one
that those depressive
states are biochemical states
it's not you
and the suggestions that these things
that this state delivers to you about
suggestion of the hopelessness of lice
or
or the meaninglessness of it or
that you should hit the eject button
that's a false reality
yeah and that it's when
i i completely understand their rational
decision to commit suicide there's it is
not lost to me at all that that is a and
that is an irrational
situation but the key is when you're in
that situation those thoughts are
landing
to be able to say thank you you're not
real
i know you're not real yeah and so i'm
in a situation where for whatever reason
i'm having this
this uh neurochemical state but
that state can be altered and so it
again it goes back to the realities of
the difficulties of of being human and
like when i was trying to solve my
depression i
tried literally ev you name it i tried
it
systematically and nothing would fix it
and so
this is what gives me hope with brain
interfaces for example like could i have
numbers on my brain
can i see what's going on because i go
to the doctor and it's like how do you
feel i don't know
terrible like on a scale of 10 how bad
you want to commit suicide
10. okay at this moment here's
here's his bottle how much i take well i
don't know like just
yeah it's very very crude and this data
opens up the
the yeah it opens up the possibility of
really helping
in those dark moments to first
understand
the the waves the ups and downs of those
dark moments on the complete flip side
of that i
i am uh very conscious in my own brain
and deeply deeply grateful that
what they're it's it's almost like a
chemistry thing a biochemistry thing
that i go many times throughout the day
i'll i'll look at like this cup
and i'll be overcome with joy how
amazing it is to be alive
like i actually think i'm my
biochemistry is such that it's not
as common like i've talked to people
and i don't think that's that common
like it's a
and it's not a rational thing at all
it's like
i feel like i'm on drugs and i'll just
be like
whoa a lot of people talk about like the
meditative experience
will allow you to sort of you know look
at some basic things like the movement
of your hand
as uh deeply joyful because it's like
that's life
but i get that from just looking at a
cup like i'm waiting for the coffee to
brew
and i'll just be like [ __ ]
life is awesome and i'll sometimes tweet
that but then i'll like regret it later
like god damn it you're so
uh ridiculous but yeah so but that
is purely chemistry like
there's no rational it doesn't fit with
the rest of my life i have all this [ __ ]
i'm always late to stuff i'm always like
there's all stuff
you know i'm super self-critical like
really self-critical about everything i
do
i'm to the point i almost hate
everything i do but
there's this engine of joy for life
outside of all that
and that has to be chemistry and the
flip side of that is what depression
probably is
is the opposite of that feeling of
like because i i bet you that feeling of
the cup being amazing is would save
anybody in a state of depression like
that that would be like fresh
you're in a desert and it's a drink of
water
[ __ ] man the brain is uh it would be
nice to understand where that's coming
from
to to be able to um to understand the
how you hit those lows and those highs
that have nothing to do with the actual
reality it has to do with some very
specific aspects
of how you maybe see the world maybe it
could be just like basic habits that you
engage in and then how to
walk along the line to to find those
experiences of joy and this goes back to
the discussion we're having of
human cognition is in volume
the largest input of raw material into
society
yeah and it's not quantified we have no
bearings on it
and so we just you wonder
we both articulated some of the
challenges we have in our own mind
and it's likely that others would say
i have something similar yeah and you
wonder when you look at society
what how does that contribute to all the
other
compounded problems that we're
experiencing how does that
blind us to the the opportunities we
could be looking at
and so it really it has this potential
distortion effect on reality that just
makes
everything worse and i hope
if we can put some if we can
assign some numbers to these things just
to get our bearings
so we're aware of what's going on if we
could find greater stabilization
in how we conduct our lives and how we
build society
it it might be the thing that enables us
to scaffold
uh because we've really again we've done
a humans have done a fantastic job
systematically scaffolding
technology and science institutions
it's humans it's our own selves which we
have not been able to scaffold it's it's
we are the
we are the one part of this intelligence
infrastructure
that remains unchanged
is there something you could say about
coupling
this brain data with uh not just the
basic human experience but say
an experience you mentioned sleep but
the wildest experience which is
psychedelics
is there and there's been quite a few
studies
now that are being um approved and run
which is exciting from a scientific
perspective
on psychedelics uh do you think
uh what do you think happens to the
brain on psychedelics
and how can data about this help us
understand it
and uh when you're on dmt do you see
else and can we guess
can we convert into data um can you add
aliens in there
yeah aliens definitely do you actually
meet aliens and elves are
elves the aliens i'm asking for uh for a
few austin friends yet
that that are convinced that they've
actually met the elves
what are elves like are they friendly
are they healthy i haven't met them
the smurfs of like they're like they're
industrious and they have different
skill sets and
yeah i think they're very uh they're
very
critical as friends that's what they're
trolls the elder
trolls no but they care about you so
there's a bunch of different version of
trolls there's there's a loving trolls
that
are harsh on you but they want you to be
better and there's trolls that just
enjoy
the your destruction and i think they're
the ones that care for you
like i i think they're criticism for my
see i'm i'm talking i haven't met him
directly so i'm i'm
it's like a friend of a friend yeah i'm
getting a telephone
yeah a bit of a and and the whole point
is that in psychedelics
and certainly at dmt where this is where
the
the the brain data versus war data
fails which is you know words can't
convey the experience
most people that you can be poetic and
so on but it really does not convey the
experience of what
what it actually means to meet the uh to
meet the elves i mean to me what
baselines this conversation is imagine
if you
if we were interested in the health of
your heart
and we started and said okay lex
self-introspect tell me how's the health
of your heart you sit there and you
close your eyes and you think
it feels all right like things seem
things feel okay
and then you went to the cardiologist
and the cardiologist like hey lex
you know tell me how you feel actually
what i'd really like
you to do is do an ekg and a blood panel
and look at arterial plaques
and let's look at my cholesterol and
there's like
five to ten studies you would do they
then give you this report and say here's
the quantified health of your heart now
with this data
i'm going to prescribe the following
regime of exercise and maybe i'll put
you on a statin
like et cetera but the protocol is based
upon this data you would
think the cardiologist is out of their
mind if they just gave you a bottle of
statins
based upon you're like well i think
something's kind of wrong and they're
just just kind of
experiment and see what happens that's
what we do with our mental health today
so you're it's it's kind of absurd and
so if you look at psychedelics
to have again to be able to measure the
brain and get a baseline state
and then to measure during a psychedelic
experience and post a psychedelic
experience then do it longitudinally
you now have a quantification of what's
going on and so
you could then pose questions what
molecule is appropriate
at what dosages at what frequency in
what contextual environment
what happens when i have this diet with
this molecule with this experience
all the experimentation you do when you
have good sleep data or
hrv and so that's what i think happens
what we could potentially do with
psychedelics is we could add this level
of sophistication
that is not in the industry currently
and it may
improve the outcomes people experience
it may improve the safety and efficacy
and so that's what i hope we are able to
achieve and
it would transform mental health
because we would finally have numbers to
work with to baseline ourselves and then
if you think about it we when we talk
about things related to the mind we talk
about the modality we use words like
meditation or psychedelics or
or something else because we can't talk
about a marker in the brain we can't use
a word to say
we can't talk about cholesterol we don't
talk about plaque in the arteries we
don't talk about
hrv and so if we have numbers then
the solutions get mapped to numbers
instead of the modalities being the
thing we talk about meditation just does
good things in a crude fashion
so in your blog post zeroth principle
thinking good title you ponder how do
people come up with uh truly original
ideas
uh what what's your thoughts on this as
a human
and as a person who's measuring brain
data zeroth
principles are building blocks
first principles are understanding of
system laws
so if you take for example like in
sherlock holmes he's a first principle
thinker
so he says once you've eliminated
the impossible anything that remains
however improbable
is true whereas dirk gently the holistic
detective by douglas adams
says i don't like eliminating the
impossible
so when someone says from a first
principal's perspective
and they they're trying to assume the
fewest number of things
within a given time frame and so when i
after braintree venmo
i set my mind to the question of
what single thing can i do that would
maximally increase the probability that
the human
race thrives beyond what we can even
imagine
and i found that in my conversations
with others in the books i read
in my own deliberations i had a missing
piece of the puzzle
because i didn't feel like uh over if
yeah i didn't feel like the future
could be deduced from first principle
thinking
and that's when i i read the book zero a
biography of a dangerous idea
and i i have a really good book by the
way it's
i think it's my favorite book i've ever
read it's also a really interesting
number
zero and i i wasn't aware that the
number zero had to be discovered i
didn't realize that it caused a
revolution in philosophy and
it just tore up math and it tore up i
mean it builds modern society but it
it wrecked everything in its way it was
an unbelievable disrupter and it
was so difficult for society to get
their heads around it
yeah and so zero is of course the
representation of zeroth principle
thinking which is it's
the caliber and consequential nature of
an idea
and so when you talk about what kind of
ideas
have civilization transforming
properties
oftentimes they fall in the zeroth
category and so
in thinking this through i i was wanting
to find a
quantitative structure on how to think
about
these zeroth principles and that's so i
came up with that
to be a coupler with first principle
thinking and so now it's a staple as
part of how i think about
the world in the future so it emphasizes
trying to identify
the lands on that word impossible like
what is impossible
essentially trying to identify what is
impossible and what is possible and
being
as how do you i mean
this this is the thing is most of
society tells you
the range of things they say is
impossible is very wide so you need to
be shrinking that
i mean that's the whole process of of
this kind of thinking is you need to
be very rigorous in in
trying to be trying to draw the lines of
what is actually impossible
because uh very few things are actually
impossible
i don't know what is actually impossible
like uh it's the joe rogan is entirely
possible
i like that approach to uh to science
to engineering to entrepreneurship it's
entirely possible
basically shrink the impossible to zero
to very small set
yeah life constraints favor
first principle thinking because it
it enables faster action with higher
probability of success
pursuing zero with principal optionality
is expensive
and uncertain and so in a society
constrained by resources
time and money and a desire for social
status accomplishment etc
it minimizes zero principle thinking but
but the reason why i think
zeroth principle thinking should be a
staple of our shared
cognitive infrastructure is if you look
through the history of the past couple
thousand years and
let's just say we arbitrarily
we subjectively try to assess what is a
zero level zero level idea
and we say how many have occurred on
what time scales
and what were the contextual settings
for it i would argue
that if you look at alphago
when it played go from another dimension
with the the human go players when it
saw alphago's moves
it attributed it to like playing with an
alien playing
go with uh with alcohol being from
another dimension
and so if you say computational
intelligence
has an attribute of introducing
zero-like
insights then if you say
what is going to be the occurrence of
zeros in society
going forward and you could reasonably
say
probably a lot more than have occurred
and probably more at a faster pace
so then if you say what happens if you
have this computational intelligence
throughout society the manufacturing
design and distribution of intelligence
is now going to heading towards zero
you have an increased number of zeros
being produced
with a tight connection between humans
computers
that's when i got to a point and said we
cannot predict the future
with first principles thinking we can't
that cannot be our imagination set it
can't be
uh our sole anchor in this situation
that basically the future of our
conscious existence 20 30 40 50 years
is probably a zero
so just to clarify when you say
zero you're referring to basically
a truly revolutionary idea yeah
something that is currently not a
building block
of our
shared conscious existence either in the
form of knowledge
uh yeah it's currently not manifest yeah
in what we
acknowledge so zeroth principle thinking
is
playing with ideas that are so
revolutionary that we can't even
clearly reason about the consequences
once those ideas come to be
yeah or for example like einstein
that was a zeroth i would categorize it
as a zeroth principle
insight you mean generality space time
yeah
basically building upon what newton had
done and said
yes also and it just changed the
fabric of our understanding of reality
and so that was unexpected
it existed we just uh it became
it came part of our awareness and the
moves alpha go made
existed it just came into our awareness
and so it to your point
there's this question of
what do we know and what don't we know
do we think we know 99
of all things or do we think we know
0.001
of all things and that goes back to no
no no knowns and unknown unknowns
and first principles and zero principle
thinking gives us a quantitative
framework to say
there's no way for us to mathematically
try to create probabilities for these
things
therefore it would be helpful if they
were just part of our standard thought
processes
because it may encourage different
behaviors in what we do individually
collectively as a society what we aspire
to what we talk about
the possibility sets we imagine yeah
i've been
engaged in that kind of thinking uh
quite a bit
and thinking about engineering of
consciousness
i think it's feasible i think it's
possible in the language that we're
using here
it's very difficult to reason about a
world
when inklings of consciousness can be
engineered
into uh artificial systems
not from a philosophical perspective but
from an engineering perspective
i believe a good step towards
engineering consciousness
is is creating engineering the
illusion of consciousness i'm
captivated by our natural predisposition
to anthropomorphize things
and i think that's what we
i don't want to hear from the
philosophers but
i think that's what we kind of do to
each other okay
that consciousness is
created socially
that like much of the power of
consciousness
is in the social interaction i create
your consciousness no i create my
consciousness by having interaction with
you
and that that's the display of
consciousness it's the same as like the
display of emotion
emotion is created through communication
language is created through its use
and then we somehow humans kind of
especially philosophers you know the
heart problem of consciousness
really want to believe that we possess
this thing
that's like there's a there's a bot
there's a there's an
elf sitting there with the with the hat
that's or like
name tag says consciousness and they're
like feeding
this subjective experience to us as
opposed to
like it actually being an illusion that
would construct to make social
communication more effective
and so i think if you focus on
creating the illusion of consciousness
you can create some very fulfilling
experiences
in in software and so that to me is the
compelling
space of ideas to explore i agree with
you and i think
going back to our experience together
with brain interfaces on you could
imagine
if we get to a certain level of maturity
so first let's take
the the inverse of this so you and i
text back and forth and we're sending
each other emojis
that has a certain amount of information
transfer rate as we're communicating
with each other
and so in our communication with people
via email and text and whatnot we've
taken the bandwidth of human interaction
the information transfer rate and we've
reduced it
we have less social cues we have less
information to work with there's a lot
more opportunity for misunderstanding
so that is altering the conscious
experience between two individuals
and if we add brain interfaces to the
equation let's imagine now we amplify
the dimensionality of our communications
that to me is what you're talking about
which is consciousness engineering
perhaps i understand you with dimensions
so maybe i understand your hap when you
look at the cup
and you experience that happiness you
can tell me you're happy and i then do
theory of mine and say
i can imagine what it might be like to
be lex and feel happy about seeing this
cup
but if the interface could then quantify
and give me a 50 vector space model and
say
this is the version of happiness that
lex is experiencing as he looks at this
cup
then it would allow me potentially to
have much greater empathy for you and
understand you as a human of this is how
you experience
joy yes which is entirely unique from
how i experience joy even though we
assumed ahead of time
that we were having some kind of similar
experience but i agree with you that
the we do consciousness engineering
today in everything we do when we talk
to each other when we're building
products
and that we're entering into it in
a stage where it will be much more
methodical
and quantitative based and computational
in how we go about doing it which to me
i find encouraging because
i think it creates better guardrails for
to create uh ethical systems
on versus right now i feel like it's
really wild wild west
on how these interactions are happening
yeah and it's funny you focus on human
to human but that
this kind of data enables human to
machine yes
interaction which is what we're
kind of talking about when we say
engineering consciousness
and that will happen of course let's
flip that on its head let's
right now we're putting humans as the
central
node what if we gave gpt3
a bunch of human brains and said hey
gpt3
learn some manners when you speak yeah
and run your algorithms on humans brains
and see how they respond
so you can be polite and so that you can
be friendly
and so that you can be conversationally
appropriate but to inverse it to give
our machines
a training set in real time with closed
loop feedback
so that our machines were better
equipped to
find their way through our society in
polite and kind and appropriate ways
i love the idea or better yet teach it
some uh
uh have it uh read the founding
documents and
have a visit austin in texas and so that
when you ask when you tell it
why don't you learn some manners it gpt3
learns to say
no it learns what it means to be free
and a sovereign individual so that
it depends so it depends what kind of
version of gpg3 you want
one that's free one that behaves well
with the social revolution
you want you want to like you want a
socialist gpt3 you want an anarchist
gpc3
you want to polite like you take it home
to visit mom and dad gpt-3 and you want
like party and like vegas
to a strip club gpt3 you want all
flavors and then you've got to have
goal alignment between all those yeah
you know they don't want to
manipulate each other for sure
so that that's i mean you kind of spoke
to ethics
the one of the concerns that people have
in this modern world the digital data is
that of privacy and security
but privacy you know they're concerned
that when they share
data it's the same thing we feel when we
are
trust other human beings uh in being
fragile and revealing something that
we're vulnerable
vulnerable about there's a there's a
leap of faith there's a leap of trust
that that's going to be just between us
as a privacy to it and then
the challenge is when you're in the
digital space then sharing your data
with companies that use that data for
advertisement all those kinds of things
there's a hesitancy to share that much
data
to share a lot of deep personal data and
if you look at brain data
that feels a whole lot like it's richly
deeply personal data so how do you think
about privacy
with this kind of ocean of data i think
we got off
to a wrong start with the internet where
the basic rules of play
for the for the company that be was
if you're a company you can go out and
get as much information on a person
as you can find without their
approval and you can also do things to
induce them
to give you as much information and you
don't need to tell them what you're
doing with it
you can do anything on the back side you
can make money on it but
the game is who can acquire the most
information and devise the most clever
schemes
to do it that was a bad starting place
and so we are in this period where we
need to wreck we need to correct for
that
and we need to say first of all the
individual
always has control over their data
it's not a free-for-all it's not like a
game of hungry hippo but
they can just go out and grab as much as
they want so for example when your brain
data was recorded today the first thing
we did in the kernel app was
you have control over your data and so
it's individual
consent it's individual control and then
you can build up on top of that
but it has to be based upon some clear
rules of play if
everyone knows what's being collected
they know what's being done with it
and the person has control over it so
transparency and control so
everybody knows what does control look
like me my ability to delete the data if
i want yeah delete it and to know
who is being shared with under what you
know what under what terms and
conditions we haven't reached that level
of sophistication with our products of
if if you say for example hey spotify
please give me a customized playlist
according to
my neurom you know you could say you can
have access to this vector space model
but only for this duration of time and
uh and then you've got to
delete it we haven't gotten there to
that level of physician but these are
ideas we need to start talking about of
how do you how would you actually
structure permissions
yeah and i think it creates a much more
stable set
for society to build where we understand
the rules of play
and people aren't vulnerable to being
taken event
it's not fair for an individual
to be taken advantage of without their
awareness with some other practice that
some companies doing for their sole
benefit
and so hopefully we are going through a
process now where we're correcting for
these things and that
it can be an economy-wide shift that
because really these are
these are fundamentals we need to have
in place it's kind of fun to think about
like uh
in chrome when you install an extension
or like install an app it's
asking you like what permissions you're
willing to give and be cool if in the
future it says like
uh you can have access to my brain data
i mean and if it's it's not unimaginable
in the future
the big technology companies have built
a business based upon acquiring data
about you that they can then create you
a model of you and sell that
predictability
and so it's not unimaginable that you
will create with like kernel device for
example a
more reliable predictor of you than they
could and that they're asking you for
permission
to complete their objectives and you're
the one that gets to negotiate that with
them
and say sure but it's not un
unimaginable that might
be the case so there's a guy named elon
musk
and he has a company in one of the many
companies called neuralink
that has uh that's also excited about
the brain
so be interesting to hear your kind of
opinions about a very different approach
that's invasive
that requires surgery that implants
a data collection device in the brain
how do you think about the difference
between kernel and neurolink
in the approaches of
getting that stream of brain data yeah
elon and i
spoke about this a lot early on we we
met up i had started colonel
and he had an interest in printer faces
as well and we explored
doing something together him joining
kernel and ultimately it wasn't the
right
move and so he started neural link and i
continued building colonel
but it was interesting because we were
both
at this very early time where it wasn't
certain what if there was a path to
pursue
if now was the right time to do
something and then the technological
choice of doing that and so
we were both our starting point was
looking at invasive technologies
and i was building invasive technology
at the time
that's ultimately where he's gone a
little less than a year after
elon and i were engaged i shifted kernel
to do non-invasive
and we had this neuroscientist come to
colonel we were talking about he had
been doing neurosurgery for 30 years one
of the most respected neuroscientists in
the us
and we brought him to colonel to figure
out the ins and outs of his profession
and at the very end of our three hour
conversation he said
you know every 15 or so years
a new technology comes along that
changes everything
he said it's probably already here you
just can't see it yet
and my jaw dropped i thought because i i
had spoken to bob greenberg
who had built a second site first on the
optical nerve and then he did court
up an array on the optical
cortex and then i also became friendly
with um
neural pace who did who does the
implants for seizure detection
and remediation and
i saw in our in their eyes what it was
like to take something through an
implantable device through
for for a 15-year run they initially
thought of seven years
and ended up being 15 years and they
thought it'd be 100 million is you know
300
400 million and i really didn't want to
build invasive technology
it was the only thing that appeared to
be possible but then once
i spun up an internal effort to start
looking at non-invasive options we said
is there something here is there
anything here that again has the
characteristics of
it has the high quality data it could be
low-cost it could be accessible could it
make brain interfaces mainstream
and so i did a bet the company move we
shifted from non-invasive to
invasive to non-invasive so the answer
is yes to that there's something there
it's possible uh the answer is we'll see
we've now built both technologies
and they're now you experience one of
them today
we were applying
we're now deploying it so we're trying
to figure out what value is really there
but i'd say it's really too early to
express confidence
whether it's to i think it's too early
to
assess which technological choice
is the right one on what time skills
yeah time skills are really important
here very important because if you look
at the like on the invasive side
there's so much activity going on right
now of
less invasive techniques to get at
the neuron firings which would what
neural link is building
it's possible that in 10 15 years when
they're scaling that technology other
things have come along
and you'd much rather do that that thing
starts to clock again
it may not be the case it may be the
case that neural link has properly
chosen the right technology
and that that's exactly what they want
to be totally possible and it's also
possible that the paths we've chosen are
non-invasive
fall short for a variety of reasons it's
just it's unknown
and so right now the two technologies we
chose the analogy i'd give to
give you to create a baseline of
understanding is
if you think of it like the internet in
the 90s
the internet became useful when people
could do a dial-up connection
and then the page and then as as
bandwidth increased
so did the utility of that connection
and so the ecosystem improve
and so if you say what kernel flow uh
is going to give you a full screen on
the picture
of information but as you're going to be
watching a movie but the image is going
to be blurred
and the audio is going to be muffled so
it has a lower resolution of coverage
kernel flux our amyg technology is going
to give you the full movie
in 1080p okay and
neuralink is going to give you a circle
on the screen of 4k okay
and so each one has their pros and cons
and
uh it's give and take and so the
decision i made
like kernel was that these two
technologies flux and flow
were basically the answer for the next
seven years
yeah and they would give rise to the
ecosystem which would become much more
valuable than the hardware itself
and that we would just continue to
improve on the hardware over time
and you know it's early days so it's
kind of fascinating to think about that
you don't it's very true that you don't
know
uh both paths are very prom
are promising
and it's like 50 years from now
we will look back and maybe not even
remember one of them
and the other one might change the world
it's so cool how technology is i mean
that's
that's what entrepreneurship is is like
mark it's the
the zeroth principle is like you're
marching ahead into the darkness into
the fog
not knowing it's wonderful to have
someone else out there with us
doing this because if you if you look at
brainerd faces
anything that's off the shelf right now
is inadequate it's had its run for
a couple decades it's still in hacker
communities it hasn't gone to the
mainstream
the room size machines are on their own
path
but there is no answer right now of
bringing brain interfaces
mainstream and so it both
you know both they and us we've both
spent over 100 million dollars
and that's kind of what it takes to have
a go at this
because you need to build full stack i
mean that kernel
we are from the photon and the atom
through the machine learning
we have just under 100 people i think
it's something like 36 37 phds
in these specialties these areas that
there's only a few people in the world
who have these abilities
and that's what it takes to build next
generation have to
make an attempt at breaking into brain
interfaces and so we'll see over the
couple years whether it's the right time
or whether we're both too early
or whether something else comes along in
seven to ten years which is the right
thing that brings it mainstream so you
see elon is the kind of competitor
or a fellow traveler
along the path of uncertainty or both
it's a fellow traveler
it's like at the beginning of the
internet is
how many companies are going to be
invited to
this new ecosystem
like an endless number because if you
think that the hardware
just starts the process and so if you
okay back to your initial example if you
take the fitbit for example you say okay
now i can get
measurements on the body and what do we
think the ultimate value of this device
is going to be what is the information
transfer rate
and they were in the market for a
certain duration of time and google
bought them for
two and a half billion dollars they
didn't have ancillary value add there
weren't people building on top of
the fitbit device they also didn't have
increased
insight with additional data streams so
it's really just the device
if you look for example at apple and the
device they sell you have value in the
device that someone buys but also
you have everyone who's building on top
of it you have this additional ecosystem
value and then you have
additional data streams that come in
which increase the value of the product
and so if you say if you look at the the
hardware
as the instigator of value creation
you know over time it what we've built
may constitute five or ten percent of
the value of the overall ecosystem and
that's what we
really care about what we're trying to
do is kick-start the mainstream adoption
of quantifying the brain and the
hardware
just opens the door to say what kind of
ecosystem could exist
and that's why we the examples are so
relevant of the things you've outlined
in your life
we hope i hope those things the books
people write
the experiences people build the
conversations you have your relationship
with your ai
systems i hope those all are feeding on
the insights
built upon this ecosystem we've created
to better your life
and so that's the thinking behind it
again with the drake equation being the
underlying
driver of value and you know the people
at colonel have joined
not because we have certainty of
success but because we find it to be the
most exhilarating opportunity we could
ever pursue
in this time uh to be alive
you founded the payment system braintree
in 2007
that acquired venmo in 2012 and then
in that same year was acquired by paypal
which is now ebay
can you tell me the story of the vision
and the challenge of building an online
payment system and just building a large
successful business
in general i discovered payments by
accident
as i was when i was 21
i i just returned from ecuador
living the money extreme poverty for two
years and i came back to the u.s and i
was
shocked by the opulence and
[Music]
yeah of the united states and i just
thought this is i couldn't believe it
and i decided i wanted to try to spend
my life
helping others that was the that was a
life objective that i thought was
worthwhile to pursue versus making money
and
whatever the case may be for its own
right and so i decided in that moment
that i was going to
try to make enough money by the age of
30
to never have to work again and then
with some abundance of money
i could then choose to do things that
might
be beneficial to others but may not meet
the criteria of being
you know a standalone business and so in
that process i started
a few companies had some small successes
had some
failures in one of the endeavors i was
up to my eyeballs in debt
things were not going well and i needed
a part-time job to
pay my bills and so i
one day i saw in the paper in utah where
i was living
the 50 richest people in utah and i
emailed each one of their assistants and
said you know i
i'm young i'm resourceful i'll do
anything i just wanna
i'm entrepreneurial i tried to get a job
that would be flexible and
no one responded and then i interviewed
at a few dozen places nobody would even
give me the time of day
like it wouldn't want to take me
seriously and so finally i
it was on monster.com that i saw this
job posting for
credit card sales door-to-door
commission i did not know the story this
is great
i love the head drop that's exactly
right so it was
the low points to which we go in life so
i
i responded and you know the person made
an attempt at
suggesting that they had some kind of
standards that they would
consider in hiring but it's kind of like
if you could fog a mirror
like you come and do this because it's
100 commission and so i started walking
up and down the street in my community
selling credit card processing and so
what you learn immediately in doing that
is if you you walk into a business first
of all
the business owner is typically there
it's
and you walk in the door and they can
tell by how you're addressed or how you
walk whatever their pattern recognition
is
and they just hate you immediately it's
like stop wasting my time i really am
trying to get stuff done i don't want to
do a sales pitch
and so you have to overcome the initial
get out
and then once you engage when you say
the word credit card processing
the person's like i already hate you
because i have been taken advantage of
dozens of times because you all are
yeah weasels and so i had to figure out
an algorithm to get past all those
different conditions because i was still
working on my other startup uh for
the majority of my times i was doing
this part time and so i figured out that
the industry really was built on
people on deceit
basically people promising things that
that were not reality and so i'd walk
into a business and say look
i would give you 100 i'd pull out a
hundred dollar bill and say i'll give
you a hundred dollars for three minutes
of your time
if you don't say yes to what i'm saying
i'll give you a hundred dollars and then
you usually crack a smile and say okay
what do you got for me son and so i'd
sit down i just open my book and i'd say
here's the credit card industry here's
how it works here are the players here's
what they do here's how they deceive you
here's what i am i'm no different than
anyone else it's like you're gonna
process your credit card you're gonna
get the money in the account you're just
gonna get a clean statement you're gonna
have someone who
answers the call when someone asks and
you know just like the basic like you're
okay
and people started saying yes and then
of course i went to the next business
and be like you know
joe and susie and whoever said yes too
and so i built a social proof structure
and i became the number one salesperson
out of
400 people nationwide doing this and i
worked you know half time still doing
another startup and
that's a brilliant strategy by the way
it's very well
very well strategized and executed
i did it for nine months and at the time
my
customer base was making was generating
around
i think a sick if i remember correctly
sixty two thousand five hundred four
dollars a month
were the overall revenues i thought wow
that's amazing if i
built that as my own company i would
just make sixty two thousand dollars a
month of income passively
with these merchants processing credit
cards so i thought hmm
and so uh that's when i thought i'm
going to create a company and so then
i started braintree and the idea was the
online world was broken because
paypal had a uh had been acquired by
ebay
around i think 2000 1999 or 2000 and
ebay had not innovated much with paypal
so
it basically sat still for seven years
as
the software world moved along and then
authorized.net was also a company that
was relatively stagnant so you basically
had
software engineers who wanted modern
payment tools but there were none
available for them and so they just
dealt with software they didn't like and
so with braintree
i thought the entry point is to build
software that engineers will love
and if we can find the entry point via
software make it easy and beautiful and
just a magical experience and then
provide customer service on top of that
it was easy that would be great
what i was really going after for though
was it was paypal they were the only
company in payments making money
because they because they had the
relationship with ebay early on
people created a paypal account they'd
fund their account with their checking
account versus their credit cards
and then when they'd use paypal to pay a
merchant paypal had a cost of payment of
zero
versus if you have coming from a credit
card you have to pay the bank the fees
so paypal's margins were
three percent on a transaction
versus a typical payments company which
may be a nickel or a penny or a dime or
something like that
and so i knew a new paypal really was
the model to replicate but
a bunch of companies had tried to do
that they tried to come in and build a
two-sided marketplace
so get consumers to fund the checking
account and merchants to accept it
but they'd all failed because building a
two-sided marketplace is very hard
at the same time so my plan was i'm
going to build a company
and get the best merchants in the whole
world to use our service
then in year five i'm going to have i'm
going to acquire a consumer payments
company and i'm going to bring the two
together
wow and so focus on the merchant side
exactly and then get the payments
company does the the customer the
whatever the the other side yeah this is
the planet presented
uh when i was at the university of
chicago and
weirdly it happened exactly like that so
for four years in
our customer base included uber airbnb
github
37 signals now base camp we had a
fantastic collection of
companies that represented the fastest
growing
some of the fastest growing tech
companies in the world and then
we met up with venmo and they had done a
remarkable job
in building products then something very
counterintuitive which is make public
your private financial transactions
which people previously thought were
something that should be hidden from
others and we acquired venmo
and at that point we now had we
replicated the model because now people
could fund their venmo account with
their checking account keep money in the
account
and then you could just plug them one as
a form of payment and so
i think paypal saw that that we were
getting the best merchants in the world
we had people using venmo they were both
the up and coming millennials at the
time who had so much influence online
and so they came in and offered us uh an
attractive number
and my my goal was not to
build the biggest payments company in
the world it wasn't
to try to climb the forbes billionaire
list it was
the objective was i want to earn enough
money
so that i can basically dedicate my
attention to doing something that could
potentially be useful
on a society-wide skill and
uh more importantly that could be
considered to be valuable
from the vantage point of 2050
2100 and 2500 so
thinking about it on a a few hundred
year time scale
and there was a certain amount of money
i needed to do that so i didn't
require the permission of anybody to do
that and so that
what paypal offered was sufficient for
me to get that amount of money to
basically have a go
and that's when i set off to
survey everything i could identify in
existence to say
of anything in the entire world i could
do what one thing could i do
that would actually have the highest
value
potential for the species and so it took
me a little while to arrive at brain
interfaces but
you know payments in themselves
are revolutionary technologies that can
change
the world like let's not
let's not uh sort of um let's not forget
that too easily i mean obviously
you know this but there's uh
quite a few lovely folks who are now
fascinated with the space of
cryptocurrency
and uh where payments are very much
connected to this but in general just
money
and many of the folks i've spoken with
they also kind of connect that to
not just purely financial discussions
but philosophical and political
discussions
and they see bitcoin as a way
almost as activism almost as a way to
resist
the the corruption of centralized the
centers of power
and sort of basically in the 21st
century decentralizing control
whether that's bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies they see
that's one possible way to give power to
those that live in uh regimes that are
corrupt
or are not respectful of human rights
and all those kinds of things
what's your sense just all your
expertise with
with payments and seeing how that
changed the world what's your sense
about
the lay of the land for the future of
bitcoin or other cryptocurrencies
in the positive impact it may have in
the world
and to be clear my communication wasn't
suggest
wasn't meant to minimize payments or to
denigrate it in any way
it was a an attempted communication that
when i was surveying the world it was an
algorithm of
what could i individually yes do
so there's there are things that exist
that have a lot of potential that can be
done
and then there's a filtering of how many
people are qualified to do this given
thing
and then there's a further
characterization that can be done of
okay given the number of qualified
people
will somebody be uh a unique out
performer of that group to make
something truly impossible to be
something done that otherwise couldn't
get done so there's
there's a process of assessing where can
you add unique value in the world
and some of that has to do with you're
being very uh
very formal and calculative here but
some of that is just like
what do you sense like part of that
equation
is how much passion you sense within
yourself to be able to drive that
through
to discover the impossibilities and make
them possible that's right and so we
we were a braintree i think we were the
first company to integrate coinbase
into our i think we were the first
payments company
to formally incorporate
uh crypto if i'm not mistaken for people
who are not familiar coinbase
is a place where you can trade
cryptocurrencies yeah which was one of
the only
places you could so we were early uh in
in doing that
and of course this was in the year 2013.
so an attorney to go in in
cryptocurrency land
i concur with the the statement you made
of the potential of
the principles underlying
cryptocurrencies
and that many of the things that they're
building
in the name of money and of
of moving value is equally applicable to
the brain
and equally applicable to how the brain
interacts with the rest of the world
and how we would imagine doing goal
alignment
with people so it's to me it's a
continuous spectrum
of possibility and we're talk your
question is isolated on the money
and i think it just is basically a
scaffolding layer for all of society so
you don't see the
this money is particularly distinct from
i don't it's i think we
we at colonel we will benefit greatly
from the progress being made in
cryptocurrency because it will be a
similar technology stack we will want to
use
for many things we want to accomplish
and so i'm
bullish on what's going on and i
think it could greatly enhance uh brain
interfaces and the value of
the brain face ecosystem i mean is there
something you could say about
first of all bullish on cryptocurrency
versus fiat money
so do you have a sense that in 21st
century cryptocurrency will
be embraced by governments and changed
of
the the face of governments the
structure of government it's the
it's the same way i think about
my diet where previously it was
conscious brian looking at foods
in certain biochemical states am i
hungry am i irritated am i depressed and
that i choose
based upon those momentary windows do i
eat at night when i'm
fatigued and i have low willpower am i
going to pig out on something
and the current monetary system is based
upon
human conscious decision making and
politics and power and
this whole mess of things and what i
like about
the building blocks of cryptocurrency is
it's methodical it's structured
it is uh accountable it's transparent
and so it introduces this scaffolding
which i think again is the right
starting point
for how we think about building next
generation
institutions for society and that's why
i think it's much broader much broader
than money
so i guess what you're saying is bitcoin
is the demotion of the conscious mind as
well
in the same way you were talking about
diet it's like giving less priority to
the
the ups and downs of any one particular
human mind in this case
your own and uh giving more power to the
sort of data driven
yes yeah i i think that is
accurate that cryptocurrency
is a version of
what i would call my autonomous self
that i'm trying to build yeah
it is an introduction of an autonomous
system
of value exchange and value
and the process yeah of value creation
in society yes
that's their similarities so i guess
what you're saying is bitcoin will
somehow help me not pig out at night
or the equivalent of speaking of diet
if we could just linger on that uh that
topic a little bit
we already talked about your your blog
post of i
i fired myself i fired brian the the
evening
brian who was uh too willing to
uh not not making good decisions for the
long-term well-being and happiness
of the entirety of the organism uh
basically you were like pigging out at
night and but it's
interesting because i do this i do the
same
in fact i often eat one meal a day
and uh like i have been this this week
actually especially when i travel
and it's it's funny that uh
it never occurred to me to just
basically look at the fact that i'm able
to be much smarter about my eating
decisions in the morning in the
afternoon than i am at night
so if i eat one meal a day why not eat
that one meal a day
in the morning like i'm not
it never occurred to me this
revolutionary yeah
until until you've uh you've outlined
that so maybe
can you give some details and what this
is just you this is one person brian
arrives at a particular thing that they
do but it's fascinating
uh to kind of look at this one
particular case study so
what works for you diet-wise what's your
actual diet what do you eat
how often do you eat my current protocol
is
basically the the result of thousands of
experiments
and decision making so i've i do this
every 90 days i do the tests
i do the cycle throughs then i measure
again and then
i'm measuring all the time and so what i
i of course i'm
optimizing for my biomarkers i want
perfect cholesterol and i brought
perfect
blood glucose levels and perfect dna
methylation
you know processes
i also want perfect sleep and so for
example
recently the past two weeks my resting
heart rate
has been a 42 when i sleep and when my
resting heart rate's at 42
my hrv is at its highest and i wake up
in the morning
feeling more energized than any other
configuration
and so i know from all these processes
that eating at roughly 8 30 in the
morning
right after i work out on an empty
stomach creates enough
distance between that completed eating
and bedtime where
i have no almost no digestion processes
going on
in my body therefore my resting heart
rate goes very low
and when my heart rate is very low i
sleep with high quality and so basically
i've been trying to optimize
the entirety of what i eat to my sleep
quality
and my sleep quality then of course
feeds into my willpower so it creates
this
virtuous cycle and so what i at 830 what
i do is i eat
what i call super veggie which is it's a
pudding
of 250 grams of broccoli 150 grams of
cauliflower and a whole bunch of other
vegetables
that i eat what i call nutty pudding
which is make the pudding yourself like
red like veg like
the um what do you call it like a veggie
mix whatever
thing is that like a blender yeah the
pasta can be made in a high-speed
blender but basically i eat the same
thing
every day veggie bowl as in the form of
pudding
and then a bowl in the form of nuts
and then i have vegan vegan yes vegan
and so
that's fat and that's like uh there's
fat and carbs
and protein and so on everything tastes
good
i'd love it i i love it so much i dream
about it
yeah that's awesome this is uh and then
i have a third dish which is it changes
every day
uh today was kale and spinach and sweet
potato
and then i take about 20 supplements
that hopefully make
constitute a perfect nutritional profile
so what i'm trying to do is
create the perfect diet for my body
every single day
or sleep as part of the optimization
that's right you're like one of the
things you're really tracking me
can you well i have a million questions
but 20 supplements like what kind or
like would you say are essential because
i only take i only take uh
athletic athletic greens.com
that's like the multivitamin essentially
yeah that's like the lazy man you know
like
like if you don't actually want to think
about [ __ ] that's what you take and then
uh fish oil and that's it that's all i
take
yeah you know alfred north whitehead
said advan uh civilization
advances as it extends the number of
important operations it can do
without thinking about them yes and so
my objective on this is i want an
algorithm
for perfect health that i never have to
think about
and then i want that system to be
scalable to anybody so that they don't
have to think about it
and right now it's expensive for me to
do it it's time consuming for me to do
it and i have
infrastructure to do it but the future
of being human
is not going to the grocery store and
deciding what to eat
it's also not reading scientific papers
trying to decide this thing or that
thing it's
all n of one it's so it's the it's
devices on the outside and inside your
body
assessing real time what your body needs
and then creating closed
systems for that to happen yeah so right
now you're doing the data collection
and you're being the scientist it'd be
much better if you're doing just that
if you just did the data collect or it
was being essentially done for you and
you can
outsource that to another scientist
that's doing the no one study of you
that's right because every time i spend
time thinking about this or executing
spending time on i'm spending less time
thinking about
building kernel or or the future of
being human and so it's
we just all have this the budget of
our capacity on everyday basis and
we will scaffold our way up out of this
and so yeah hopefully that what i'm
doing
is really it serves as a model uh that
others can also
you build that's why that's why i wrote
about it is hopefully people can take it
and improve upon it
uh i hold nothing sacred i change my
diet
almost every day based upon some new
test results or science or something
like that but
can you maybe elaborate on the sleep
thing why is sleep so important
and why presumably if like
what does good sleep mean to you
i think sleep is a contender for
being the most powerful
health intervention in existence
it's a contender i mean it's uh it's
magical what it does if you're well
rested
and what your body can do
and i mean for example i know when when
i eat
close to my bedtime and i've done a
systematic study
for years looking at like 15 minute
increments on time of day on where i eat
my last meal
my willpower is directly correlated to
my to the amount of deep sleep i get
so my ability to not binge eat at night
when rascal brian's out and about
is based upon how much deep sleep i got
the night before yeah and so
there's some there's a lot to that yeah
and so i just i've seen it
manifest itself and so the i think
the way i summarize this is in society
we've had this myth
of we tell stories for example of
entrepreneurship
where this person was so amazing they
stayed at the office for three days and
slept under their desk
and we say wow that's amazing there's
that's amazing
and now i think we're headed towards a
state where we'd say
that's primitive and really not a good
idea
on every level and so
the new mythology is going to be the
exact opposite
yeah by the way just to sort of maybe
push back a little bit on that idea
uh did you sleep under your desk
collects
well yeah a lot i'm not a big believer
in that actually i'm a big believer in
in chaos and not giving and like giving
in to your passion
and sometimes doing things that are out
of the ordinary that are
like not trying to optimize health for
certain periods of time
in uh in lieu of your passions
is a signal to yourself that you're
throwing everything away so
i think what you're referring to is
how to have good performance for
prolonged periods of time
i think there's there's moments in life
when you need to throw all that away
all the plans away all the structure way
so the
i i don't this i'm not sure
i have an eloquent way of describing
exactly what i'm talking about but
it all depends on different on people
people are different
but there's a danger of over
optimization
to where you don't just give in to the
madness
of the way your brain flows
i mean to push back on my pushback is
like
it's nice to have like where the k
where the foundations
of your brain are not messed with so you
have a fixed foundation where the diet
is fixed
where the sleep is fixed and that all
that is optimal and the chaos happens in
the space of ideas as opposed to the
space of biology
but you know i i'm not sure if there's a
uh that requires real discipline and
forming habits
there's some aspect to which some of the
the best
uh days and weeks of my life have been
yeah sleeping under a desk kind of thing
and i don't i'm not too willing to
let go of things that empirically worked
for things that uh work in theory
and so i'm i'm again i'm absolutely with
you on sleep
also i'm with you on sleep conceptually
but
i'm also very humbled to understand that
for
different people good sleep means
different things
i'm very hesitant to trust science on
sleep
i think you should also be a scholar of
your own body again
experiment of n of one i'm not so
sure that a full night's sleep is great
for me
there is something about that power nap
that i just have not fully studied yet
but that nap is something special
i'm not sure i found the optimal thing
yeah
so like there's a lot to be explored to
what is exactly optimal
amount of sleep optimal kind of sleep
combined with diet and all those cousins
i mean that all maps the sort of data at
least the truth
exactly what all everything you're
referring to here's a data point for
your consideration
yes the progress in biology
over the past say decade has been
stunning
yes and it now appears as if
we will be able to replace
are organs xenox transplantation
and so we probably have a path
to replace and regenerate every organ of
your body
except for your brain
you can you can lose your hand and your
arm and leg you can have an artificial
heart
you can't operate without your brain and
so when
you make that trade-off decision of
whether you're going to sleep under the
desk or not and go all out
for a four-day marathon
right there's a there's a cost-benefit
trade-off of what's going on what's
happening to your brain in that
situation
we don't know the consequences of modern
day life on our brain
we don't it's the most valuable organ
in our existence and we don't know
what's going on if we in how we're
treating it today with
stress and with sleep and with dietary
and to me then if you say
that you're trying to you're you're
trying to optimize life for whatever
things you're trying to do the game is
soon with the progress in anti-aging and
biology the game is very soon going to
become different than what it is right
now
uh with organ rejuvenation organ
replacement and
i'm i would conjecture that
we will value the health status of our
brain
above all things yeah no absolutely
everything's you're saying is true but i
we die we die pretty quickly life is
short
and i'm one of those people that uh
i would rather die in battle than uh
then stay
safe at home it's like yeah
you you look at kind of there's a lot of
things that you can reasonably say that
this is the smart thing to do
that can prevent you that becomes
conservative that can prevent you from
fully embracing life
i think ultimately you can be very
intelligent
and data driven and also embrace life
but i er on the side of embracing life
it's very
it takes a very skillful person to not
sort of that
hovering parent that says no you know
what there's a
three percent chance that if you go out
if you go
by yourself and play you're going to die
get run over by a car
come to a slow or a sudden end
and uh i'm more a supporter of
just go out there if you die you die and
that's a you it's a balance you have to
strike i think long
there's a balance of striking long-term
optimization
and uh short-term
freedom for me for programmer
for a programming mind i tend to over
optimize and i'm
very cautious and afraid of that to not
over optimize and thereby be overly
cautious
suboptimally cautious about everything i
do
and that's the ultimate thing i'm trying
to optimize for it's funny you said like
sleep and all those kinds of things
i tend to think this is uh you're being
more precise
than i am but i think i tend to want to
minimize stress
which everything comes into that from
your sleep and all those kinds of things
but
i worry that whenever i'm trying to be
too strict with myself then the stress
goes up
when i don't follow the strictness and
so
you have to kind of it's a weird it's a
there's so many variables in an
objective function as
it's hard to get right and sort of not
giving a damn about sleep and not giving
a damn
bad diet is a good thing to inject in
there every once in a while
for somebody who's trying to optimize
everything that's
but that's me just trying to uh like
it's exactly like you said
you're just a scientist i'm a scientist
of myself you're a scientist of yourself
it'd be nice if somebody else was doing
it and had much better data
than uh because i don't trust my
conscious mind and i pigged out last
night at some brisket
in la that uh i regret deeply it's still
uh there's no point to anything i just
said
what what is the nature of your regret
on the brisket is it do you wish you
hadn't
eaten it entirely is it that you wish
you hadn't as much as you did is it
that i think uh
well the most regret i mean if we
want to be specific i drank
way too much like diet soda my biggest
regret is like having drank so much diet
soda
that's the thing that really was the
problem i had trouble sleeping because
of that
because i was like programming and then
i was editing and so i stayed up late at
night and then i had to get up to
to go pee a few times and it was just a
mess and the mess of the night
it was well it's not really a mess but
like it's so many
it's like the little things i know if i
just
eat i i drink a little bit of water and
that's it and
there's a certain all of us have perfect
days
that we know diet wise and so on that's
good to follow you feel good
i know what it takes for me to do that i
didn't fully do that
and thereby because there's there's an
avalanche effect where the other sources
of stress
all the other to do items i have pile on
my failure to execute on some basic
things that i know make me feel good and
all that combines
to uh you know to create to create a
mess of a day
but some of that chaos you know you have
to be okay with it but some of it i wish
was uh was a little bit more optimal
and your ideas about eating in the
morning are quite interesting
as an experiment to try can you
elaborate
are you eating once a day yes
in the morning and that's it can you
maybe
speak to how that you spoke
it's funny he spoke about the metrics of
sleep
but you're also you know and you
run a business you're incredibly
intelligent you have to
most of your happiness and success
relies on you
thinking clearly so how does that affect
your mind
and your body in terms of performance so
not just sleep but actually like mental
performance
as you were explaining your objective
function of for example in the criteria
you were
including you like certain neurochemical
states like you
like feeling like you're living life
that life has enjoyment
that sometimes you want to disregard
certain rules to
have a moment of passion of focus
there's this architecture of
the way lex is which makes you happy as
a story you tell
as something you kind of experience
maybe the experience is a bit more
complicated but it's in this idea you
have this is a version of you
and the reason why i maintain the
schedule i do
is i've chosen a game to say i would
like to live a life
where i care more about what
intelligent what people
who live in 2000 the year 2500 think of
me
than i do today that's the game i'm
trying to play
and so therefore the only thing
i really care about on this optimization
is
trying to see past myself past my
limitations
using xero's principle thinking
pull myself out of this contextual mesh
we're in right now and say
what will matter a hundred years from
now and 200 years from now
what are the big things really going on
that are defining reality
and i find that if i
were to hang out with diet soda lex
and diet soda brian were to play along
with that and my deep sleep were to get
crushed as a result my mind would not be
on what matters
in 100 years or 200 or 300 years i would
be irritable
i would be you know i'd be in a
different state and so
it's just gameplay selection it's what
you and i have chosen to think about
it's what we've chosen to
uh work on and this is why i'm saying
that no
generation of humans have ever been
afforded the opportunity to look at
their lifespan
and contemplate that
they will have the possibility of
experiencing
an evolved form of consciousness that is
unidentifiable it would fall in a zeroth
category
of potential that to me is the most
exciting thing in existence and i would
not trade
any momentary neurochemical state
right now in exchange for that i would
i'd be willing to deprive myself of all
momentary joy
in the pursuit of that goal because
that's what makes me happy
that's brilliant but i'm uh i'm a bit i
just looked it up
i just looked up braveheart speech and
william wallace but
i know you've seen it fighting you may
die run and you'll live
at least a while and dying in your beds
many years from now
would you be willing to trade all the
days from this day to that
for one chance just one chance picture
of mel gibson's saying this
to come back here and tell our enemies
that they may take our lives
with growing excitement but they'll
never take our freedom
i get excited every time i see that in
the movie but that's kind of how i
approach life
uh and do you think they were trying to
sleep i did we're not tracking their
sleep and they ate way too much brisket
and they were
fat unhealthy died early and
uh were primitive but uh there's some
there's something in my eight brain
that's attracted to that
even though most of my life is fully
aligned
with the way you see yourself and part
of it is for comedy of course but part
of it is like
i'm almost afraid of uh over
optimization really what you're saying
though if we're
looking at this let's say from a first
principal's perspective
when you read those words they conjure
up certain life experiences
but you're basically saying i experience
a certain neurotransmitter state
when these things are an action yeah
that's all you're saying
so whether it's that or something else
you're just saying you have a selection
for how
your state for your body and so if you
as an engineer
of consciousness that should just be
engineerable
and that's just triggering certain
chemical reactions
and so whether so it doesn't mean they
have to be mutually exclusive you can
have that
and experience that and also not
sacrifice long-term health and i think
that's the potential of where we're
going is
we don't have we don't have to assume
they are trade-offs that must be had
absolutely and so i guess for my
particular brain
it's useful to have the outlier
experiences
that also come along with the uh
illusion of free will where i chose
those
that make me feel like it's freedom
listen going to texas made me realize i
spent so i was
i still am but i lived at cambridge at
mit
and i never felt like home there i felt
like home
in the space of ideas with the
colleagues like when i was actually
discussing ideas but
there is something about this the
constraints the
how cautious people are how much they
valued also kind of uh
material success career success
when i showed up to texas it felt like
i belonged that was very interesting but
that's my
neurochemistry whatever the hell that is
whatever whatever
maybe probably is rooted to the fact
that i grew up in the soviet union it
was so
such a constrained system that you'd
really deeply value freedom and you've
you always want to escape the demand and
the control of centralized systems i
don't know what it is
but that's but at the same time i love
strictness
i love the dogmatic authoritarianism of
diet
of like the same habit exactly the habit
you have i think that's actually when
bodies perform
optimally my body performs optimally so
balancing those two
i think if i have the data every once in
a while party with some wild people but
most of the time eat once a day
perhaps in the morning i'm going to try
that might be very interesting
but i'd rather i'd rather not try it i'd
rather have the data that
tells me to do it but in general you're
able to
eating once a day think deeply about
stuff like this
concern that people have is like you
know does your energy wane all those
kinds of things
do you find that it's especially because
um
it's unique it's vegan as well so you
find that you're able to have a clear
mind
a focus and just physically and mentally
throughout
yeah i find like my personal experience
in
thinking about hard things
is like oftentimes i feel like i'm
i'm looking through a telescope and like
i'm aligning two or three telescopes and
you kind of have to
close one eye and move it back and forth
a little bit and just find
just the right alignment then you find
just a sneak peek at the thing you're
trying to find but it's fleeting if you
move
just one little bit it's gone yeah and
oftentimes
what i feel like are the hot the ideas i
value the most
are like that they're so fragile
and fleeting and slippery and elusive
and it requires
a sensitivity to thinking and a
sensitivity
to maneuver through these things if i
concede to a world where i'm on my phone
texting i'm also on social media i'm
also doing 15
things at the same time because i'm
running the company and i'm also feeling
terrible from the last night
it all just comes crashing down and the
quality of my thoughts
goes to a zero i'm just a i'm a
functional
person to respond to basic level things
but i don't feel like i
i'm doing anything interesting
i think that's a good word sensitivity
because that's when you
that's that's what uh thinking deeply
feels like is you're sensitive to the
fragile thoughts
and you're right all those other
distractions kind of dull
your ability to be sensitive to the the
fragile thoughts
it's a really good word out of
all the things you've done you've also
climbed mount kilimanjaro
is this true it's true
uh what do you uh
why and how and what do you take from
that experience
i guess the backstory is relevant
because
that uh in that moment it was the
darkest time in my life i was
ending a 13-year marriage i was leaving
my religion i sold braintree and i was
coming
battling depression where i was just at
the end
and i got invited to go to
tanzania as part of a group that was
raising money to build clean water wells
and i had made some money from braintree
and so i was able to
donate 25 000 and it was the first time
i had ever had money to donate
outside of paying tithing at my religion
it was such a phenomenal experience
to to contribute something meaningful to
someone else
in that form and as part of this process
we were going to climb the mountain and
so
we went there and we saw the clean water
whales we were building we spoke to the
the people there it was very energizing
and then we climbed kilimanjaro
and i came down with
a stomach flu on on day three
and i also had altitude sickness but i
became so sick that on day four
we were summoning on day five i came
into
the camp base camp at fifteen thousand
feet uh
just you know going to the bathroom on
myself and like falling all over it was
just i was just a disaster uh i was
still sick
so stomach flu and altitude sickness
yeah and i just was destroyed from
the situation and plus
what psychologically one of the lowest
points yeah and i think that was
probably a big contributor i was
i was just smoked as a human just
absolutely done
and i had three young children and so i
was trying to reconcile like
this is not a whether whether i live or
not
is not my decision by itself i'm
now intertwined with these three little
people
and i have an obligation whether i like
it or not
i need to be there and so it did it felt
like i was just stuck in a straight
jacket
and i had to decide whether i was going
to
summit the next day with the team
and it was a difficult decision because
once you start hiking there's no way to
get off the mountain
and midnight came and our guide came in
and he said where you at and i said
i think i'm okay i think i can try and
so we we went
and so from midnight
to i made it to the summit at 5 a.m
it was one of the most transformational
moments of my existence
and the mountain
became my problem it became
everything that i was struggling with
and
when i started hiking it was the pain
got so ferocious
uh that it was kind of like this
it became so ferocious that um
i turned my music to eminem and it was
you know eminem was
is the he was the only person in
existence that spoke to my soul
and it was something about you know his
anger and his
vibrancy and his multi-bench way he's
the only person i who i could turn on
and i could say ah
like i feel some relief i turned i
turned on eminem
and um i made it to the summit uh after
five hours
but just just a hundred yards from the
top i was with my guide ike
and i started getting very dizzy and i
felt like i was
gonna fall backwards off this this cliff
area we were on i was like this is
dangerous
and uh he said look brian i i know where
you're at
i know where you're at and i can tell
you you've got it in you
so i want you to look up take a step
take a breath and look up take a breath
and take a step
and i did and i made it and so i got
there and i just
i sat down with him at the top i just
cried like a baby broke down
did just i just lost it and uh
so you know he'd let me do my thing and
then we pulled out the
the pulse oximeter and measured my blood
oxygen levels and it's like it was like
50 something percent and it was danger
zone so he so he looked at it and i
think he was like really alarmed
that i was in this situation and so uh
he said we can't get a helicopter here
and we can't get you emergency evacuated
you've got to go down you've got to hike
down to fifteen thousand feet to get
base camp
and so he we went around the mountain
i got bound back down to base camp and
um
again that was pretty difficult and then
they put me on a stretcher this metal
stretcher with this one wheel
and a team of six people wheeled me down
the mountain
and it was it was pretty torturous i'm
very appreciative they did also the
trail was very bumpy so they'd go over
these big rocks and so my head would
just slam
against this metal thing for hours and
so i just felt awful plus i'd get my
head slammed every couple seconds
yeah so the whole experience uh was
really a life-changing moment and that's
it that was the demarcation of me
basically
building a new life of basically i said
i'm going to
reconstruct brian my
my understanding of reality my
existential realities what i want to go
after
and i try i mean as much as that's
possible as a human but that's when
i set out to rebuild everything
was it the struggle of that i mean
there's also just like
the romantic poetic
it's a freaking mountain
it's a man in in pain psychological and
physical
struggling up a mountain but it's just
struggle
just uh in the in the face of
just pushing through in the face of
hardship or nature
too something much bigger than you
is that was that the thing that just
clicked for me it felt like i was just
locked in with reality and it was
a death match it was in that moment one
of us is going to die
see you were pondering death yeah like
not surviving yeah
and and it was and that was the moment
and it was uh the summit to me was
i i'm gonna come out on top and i can do
this and uh giving in was
it's like i'm just done and so it did i
locked in
and uh that's why yeah
mountains are magical to me uh
i didn't expect that i didn't design
that i didn't know that was gonna be the
case
i and not it would not have been
something i would have anticipated
but you are not the same man afterwards
is there advice you can give to uh young
people today that look at your story
that's successful in many dimensions
um advice you can give to them about how
to be successful in their career
successful in life whatever path they
choose
yes i would say listen to advice
and see it for what it is a mirror
of that person and then map
and know that your future is going to be
in a zeroth principle land
and so what you're hearing today is a
representation
of what may have been the right
principles to build upon previously
but they're likely depreciating very
fast
and so i am a strong proponent
that people ask for advice but they
don't take advice
so how do you take advice properly
it's in the careful examination of the
advice it's it's actually you
the person makes a statement about a
given thing somebody should follow
the value is not doing that the value is
understanding the assumption stack they
built the assumption and knowledge stack
they built around
that that body of knowledge that's the
value it's not doing what they say
considering the advice but digging
deeper to understand the assumption
stack
like the full person it's almost i mean
this is deep empathy essentially
to understand the journey of the person
that arrived at the advice
and the advice is just the tip of the
iceberg that's right that ultimately is
not the thing that gives you
that's right it could it could be the
right thing to do it could be the
completely wrong thing to do depending
on the assumption
stack so you need to investigate the the
whole thing
is there some are there been people in
your
startup in your business journey
that have served that role of advice
giver
has been helpful or did do you feel like
your journey
felt like a lonely path
or was it one that was of course we're
all
we all are born and die alone uh
but uh
do you fundamentally remember the
experiences one where you leaned
on people at a particular moment of time
that changed everything
yeah the most significant moments of my
memory
for example like on kilimanjaro when ike
some person i'd never met in tanzania
was able to in that moment apparently
see my soul
when i was in this death match with
reality yes
and he gave me the instructions look up
step and so
there's magical people in my life
that have done things like that and
i suspect they probably don't know i
i probably should be better at
identifying those things and
but yeah hopefully them
i suppose like the wisdom i would aspire
to
is to have the awareness and the empathy
to be that for other people and
not a a retail
advertiser of advice of tricks and
for life but deeply meaningful
and empathetic with a one-on-one context
with people that
it really could make a difference yeah
i actually kind of experienced i think
about that sometimes you know you have
like a 18 year old kid come up to you
it's not always obvious it's not always
easy
to really listen to them like not
not the facts but like see who that
person is
i think people say that about being a
parent is
you know you want to consider that
you you don't want to be the authority
figure in a sense that you you really
want to consider
that there's a special unique human
being there with a unique brain
that may be um brilliant in ways that
you are not
understanding that you'll never be and
really try to hear that
so when giving advice there's something
to that so both sides should be
deeply empathetic about the assumption
stack
i love that uh the terminology what do
you think is the meaning of this whole
thing
of life why the hell are we here
ryan johnson we've been talking about
brains and studying brains and
you had this very eloquent way of
describing life on earth as
uh as an optimization problem uh
of uh the cost of intelligence going to
zero
at first through the evolutionary
process and then eventually
through building through our technology
building
more and more intelligent systems you
ever ask yourself
why is doing that yeah i think the
answer to this question again the
information value is more in the mirror
it provides of that person which is a
representation
of the technological social political
context of the time so if you asked this
question a hundred years ago
you would get a certain answer that
reflects that time period same thing
would be true over a thousand years ago
it's rare it's difficult for a person to
pull themselves out of their contextual
awareness
yeah and offer truly original response
and so knowing that i am contextually
influenced by the situation that i am
a mirror for our reality i would say
that in this moment
i think the real game going
on is
that in evolution
built a system of scaffolding
intelligence that produced us
we are now building intelligent systems
that are scaffolding
higher dimensional intelligence this is
developing
more robust systems of intelligence
in doing in that process with the cost
going to zero
then the meaning of life becomes
goal alignment which is the negotiation
of our conscious and unconscious
existence
and then i'd say the third thing is if
we're thinking that we want to be
explorers is
our technological progress is getting to
a point where
we could aspirationally say
we want to figure out what is really
going on
really going on because does any of this
really make sense
now we may be 100 200 500 a thousand
years away from being able to
poke our way out of whatever is is going
on
but it's interesting that we could even
state an aspiration
to say we want to poke at this question
but i'd say
in this moment of time the meaning of
life
is that we can build a future state
of existence that is more fantastic than
anything we could ever imagine the
striving
for something more amazing
and that defies expectations
that we would consider bewildering
and all the things that that that's and
and i guess the last thing if there's
multiple meanings of life it would be
infinite games you know james karst
wrote the book
finite games infinite games the only
game
to play right now is to keep playing the
game
and so this goes back to the algorithm
of the lex algorithm
of diet soda and brisket and pursuing
the passion i'm what i'm suggesting is
there is a
there's a moment here where we can
contemplate playing infinite games
therefore it may make sense to err on
the side of making sure
one is in a situation to be plain
infinite games if that
opportunity arises so just the landscape
of possibilities changing very very fast
and therefore
our old algorithms of how we might
assess risk assessment and what things
we might pursue and why
those assumptions may fall away very
quickly
well i think i speak for a lot of people
when i say that
the game you mr brian johnson have been
playing
is quite incredible thank you so much
for talking today thanks lex
thanks for listening to this
conversation with brian johnson and
thank you to
four sigmatic netsuite grammarly
and expressvpn check them out in the
description to support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from diane ackerman
our brain is a crowded chemistry lab
bustling with non-stop neural
conversations
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you